make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are officially picking up
with the maestro miniseries it's a five
issue mini series and i
still say that they're gonna put maestro
in the marvel cinematic universe and
there's one particular reason why i
think this solidifies it more than
anything
but i believe they're gonna put mitro in
the mcu so what we end up doing here and
we'll have a bit of a discussion towards
the end of this about maestro himself
but one thing i do want to say to you
guys as we get into this is i do want to
say
thank you guys right the response to the
twitch stream has been awesome i think
we capped out at around 320 people
uh right now we've been sitting steady
at about 1 21 30 for the last
really about the last two days straight
uh i think we've given away something
like 12 or 13 rob core rings we're
giving away a handful of trade
paperbacks uh so if you guys want to be
a part of that
go check it out twitch.tv comics display
and you'll find
the link down in the description um and
right now i think we're covering the
full story videos and i believe
here in the next few hours we'll be
covering uh the incredible hulk
right so kind of good timing for this
for this particular comic
but um what this does is this initially
opens up uh with professor hulk
right now the reason why this matters is
twofold one because peter david's the
one writing this maestro miniseries
which is perfect because he's the one
that made the character
and two because professor hulk is the
one who originally fought maestro right
from from back in the old future
imperfect stories ah and so professor
hulk was basically the merged hulk right
it's where bruce banner ended up coming
face to face with all his different
alternate reality hulk personas
and basically kind of merged into them
and that led him to essentially have the
intelligence of bruce with all the power
of the incredible hulk
and so what this does is it is after
these sentinels are destroyed and
they're more or less taken out you then
pick up with the fact that they're
basically
the avengers here right like it and it
really looks more like the new avengers
than anything else but you've basically
got like you know
wolverine who's here you've got thor
who's there he flies off and then you're
met with betty ross and that's our first
cue to the fact that something seems a
little strange here because betty ross
was
part of bruce banner's part of professor
hulk's life but things get a little more
interesting right because it's kind of
like nothing could possibly go wrong in
this location right and when we
transition
into what looks like avengers mansion
you've got the incredible hulk and then
you've got betty and then they have two
kids and hulk and betty never had kids
as far as i'm aware of right they didn't
have like any any children or anything
you know and it's kind of nuts because
one of these things that this sort of
happens
is you know betty ross calls her kids to
sit back down and they say no we don't
have to and the question's like why and
it's like because you're dead
and that's what hulk's kind of like what
in the world is going on here and and
one of his kids is like they're dead
like everybody's dead betty ross is dead
everybody's basically gone and then
betty ross starts operating like a
computer program right
you know http error 404 right the file
name can't be found
bad command file you know all that kind
of stuff she's operating like a computer
program that's going awry
and hulk kind of starts to freak out and
what it does is everything sort of goes
black
and then it leads to the arrival of
captain america and then everything kind
of comes back on again and it's one of
these things where captain america is
like okay hang on a second the system's
kind of you know everything seems to be
going awry for for a minute mysterio's
in your mind right and that's that's the
knee-jerk explanation
that mysterio is manipulating the
incredible hulk he's manipulating bruce
banner this is one of the first reasons
why i say that i think they're going to
put maestro in the mcu because we
already know who mysterio is right so
what better character to reference at
that point they could have used any
telepath where they could have said like
emma frost is in your head or like
quentin choir is in your head and comic
book fans
for the most part know who they are but
if you're not a comic book fan if you're
somebody who's reading this or somebody
who's stumbling into comics or or you
pick this up after maestro is introduced
then you don't know who quintin choir is
but you do know who mysterio is
right so it kind of makes sense but it's
one of these things where hulk sort of
rejects it and he's like no no no that's
not the case you know when did mysterio
become so powerful that he could get
into my head and even if he was capable
of doing that
why what would be the purpose of
mysterio messing with my mind
right now for us as readers the
knee-jerk reaction is old man logan
right the villains are basically
conquering the world and they got hulk
out of the way by manipulating his mind
and basically keeping him distracted but
that's not true
instead what ends up happening is he
basically leaves the room and then he
ends up in what looks like this giant
facility
and then from there it's kind of like
okay if this is really what mysterio is
doing then it's a whole new kettle of
beans but then everything shifts up
again and you're suddenly met with black
widow and this is why i say i think
they're gonna put maestro in the mcu
because when black widow approaches the
hulk she says
the sun's getting real low that's an mcu
line that's not a marvel comics line
plus it looks like uh it looks like
black widow from the marvel cinematic
universe that's kind of why now it could
just be that marvel comics is playing on
that in order to make this transition
easier for people coming from the movies
getting into the comics but i would say
it's the other way around
i would say that basically you're you're
gonna see the maestro rolled into the
marvel cinematic universe but initially
thor tries to stop hulk and he's like no
like you're not gonna stop me if you to
get in the way of this that's fine but
then you basically end up having like
you know
the avengers turning on uh turning on
hulk trying to subdue him and of course
him using his his sonic clap that brings
them all down except for the vision and
once the vision approaches and the
vision reaches into his brain and then
essentially does something right and in
what appears to be more or less
killing the hulk and then he suddenly
wakes up in this massive facility and
this is really representative and then
really
similar to like the the weapon x
facility right the facility that was
used to transform wolverine into weapon
x where he was reprogrammed his memories
were replaced all that kind of stuff
that he eventually broke out of
that's very similar to what this looks
like but once he breaks out then
suddenly he's met by what looks like
this kind of
computerized woman more or less and this
young kid and he immediately thinks this
kid's a son
right that's his immediate reaction he
thinks they took his son right because
for the most part he's still kind of in
a state of mental chaos he doesn't fully
know what's going on and for him
this illusion might as well be as real
as the previous illusion right so he's
not really sure what's real and what's
not anymore which is really one of the
benefits if it were mysterio that's one
of the benefits of a studio is even when
you snap back to reality
at that point you don't know what's real
and what's not right it's kind of a
crazy situation it's like inception and
so ultimately
once you end up having this kid who
basically panics and starts to make
sounds like he is being you know is
being attacked more or less by hulk he
puts him down the kid runs to his mom
and that's when hulk starts to realize
okay
i'm actually here in the real world but
if i am then what in the world is going
on
and then suddenly he's met by soldiers
from advanced idea mechanics
now immediately hulk goes on the
offensive and the reason why is that for
those of you guys who
are new to marvel comics advanced idea
mechanics was the
scientific arm of hydra for a long long
time until hydra fell
and then they broke off and started
doing their own thing but advanced idea
mechanics looks to take over the world
through technological means right
through scientific means and so they're
always looking for ways to basically
improve themselves or to
to attain some sort of weapon they can
use to achieve their goal of like
world dominance and the hulk is a
perfect way to do that you're just
talking about a massive guy and if he
can be controlled and if he can be made
to go on certain attacks and then pulled
off from those attacks and sent to other
attacks
literally turn into what what is more or
less a living weapon
then you'd be one of the most powerful
forces in all of the world if not the
most powerful say for somebody like
doctor strange or somebody like that but
most countries wouldn't really be able
to stand against you and so realizing
that this is advanced idea mechanics and
realizing it's their soldiers they
initially tell him
if you don't back off we're going to
shoot you and hulk kind of starts to
call their bluff right in the sense that
like it is advanced idea mechanics as
far as a hulk is aware he's never really
had anything to fear from advanced idea
mechanics he never had to worry about
them they never really had weapons that
were really powerful enough to
completely and totally subdue the hulk
right he'd always be able to find a way
around them but when they fire these
guns
they're wildly advanced and and while
they don't necessarily kill the hulk
they do pack one heck of a punch but
this gives them the opportunity to smash
a hole in the ground
and to basically get away only to
discover that underneath him are all
these different tanks where you have
people like abomination who were kept in
a state of suspended animation right and
so it's kind of like okay
they have more of me what's going on and
that kind of kind of leads to the
question are they weaponizing hooks are
they somehow
trying to extract gamma radiation from
us and create their own hulk like
what's the whole purpose here what's
happening and so where you end up having
hulk who runs at the
the soldiers who have now arrived from
advanced idea mechanics and hits a force
field
suddenly he's shot by you know this kind
of laser that comes out of nowhere and
it's revealed to be modoc right now
modoc was the last person i expected to
see here but modok of courses is
hardcore comic book readers will know
basically stands for mental organism
design only for killing
he's more or less a person who was
converted into kind of like a machine
type thing
he's just a murderous robot right he
killed his creators and then went on his
own thing and you really haven't seen
him for a long
time in marvel comics right he was
really more of like a 70s and 80s
villain really if i
if i had to be honest i'm really more of
an 80s villain but modock first appeared
in tales of suspense number 93 i think
it was back in 1967 and he was
originally part of advanced idea
mechanics when they first created the
cosmic cube
the issue here was advanced idea
mechanics wasn't entirely sure with
of what they'd done and so the idea was
to create an organism or to
basically create something that could
essentially probe the the cosmic cube
and so they came up with what was called
the modoc project right mental organism
design only for computing and the idea
was that they would send the uh the the
you know send modoc basically into the
cosmic cube or at least have them probe
the cosmic cube to see what it was truly
capable of the issue with this
is that once george tarleton who is
which was his name before he became
modoc once he was forced into this
system uh had his
had his mind enhanced and then came out
was thrown into the doomsday chair which
is what he's on right now you ended up
finding out that basically he came to
the realization he could overpower
advanced idea mechanics
and then he started you know setting his
sights on world domination ultimately he
was defeated
you know i mean we kind of saw him pop
up try to conquer the world defeated
again that sort of a thing
but that's really where he's been ever
since he's just kind of been like a
free-floating villain it's had a couple
cool stories here and there but he's by
no means one of the most significant
threats out there now the idea that i
imagine in the mcu because they're gonna
bring modoc in
the idea behind the mcu i imagine is
that the scientific arm of hydra
as we saw during the events of like
captain america the winter soldier is
that it is gonna go forward and and
you're gonna have aim that comes out of
that and then you're gonna have the
creation of modoc if it wasn't made
already when hydra was in charge of
shield but regardless the hulk basically
starts to freak out and believes that
modoc is the one behind all this and
goes to attack him and actually asks the
question
what did you do and modoc's response is
i didn't do anything
i could have kept you back in that force
field if i wanted to but i let you
attack me as a show that i'm not the
threat here i'm not the one who's trying
to hurt you and in fact if you killed me
that would be fine because this life i'm
living is a fate worse than death and
not even because i'm strapped in this
doomsday chair but because we're stuck
down here in what is more or less
a gigantic bunker and the hulk asks like
what are you talking about and modoc
says like
we're here because of the end of the
world right we're here because the
world's dead
like there's really nothing up there
anymore and when the hulk asked who did
this was it like hydra or something like
that
what happened with this modok's response
is they it was just average joes up
there that did it and you end up finding
out that what had happened is at some
point in the past and the only real
timeline we're given here is about a
hundred years ago and we're only told
that because
the incredible hulk when he first sees
modoc says he looks like he's aged by a
hundred years and that's really the only
time frame we get and what we end up
finding out here is that at some point
some extremist group got their hands on
two nuclear bombs they detonated one in
the united states and they detonated the
other in moscow russia and what it what
they did is they in turn used the
computer systems of both of these
countries to basically lead the other to
believe
that the other one attacked so where the
white house and the capital was
obliterated through a nuclear bomb
which was detonated by these extremists
that the united states government was
tricked into believing it was russia
and vice versa and so ultimately this
basically led to
a nuclear strike basically what what
seems to what this seems to indicate
is that it led to mad right mutually
assured destruction that it was a
nuclear war
nuclear war that happened world war iii
and in all of this 60
of humanity was basically destroyed but
what you end up having is that this
extremist group ended up rising and
calling themselves the black scythe kind
of you know modeling themselves after
the
after the grim reaper and they had come
to the opinion that humanity for the
most part had outlived its place on the
earth
right that humanity was more or less
like a virus or a plague that was
spreading around the earth and making
things worse
and so their idea was to basically rid
the earth of humanity and so where all
you had left was about 40
of humanity and a lot of those
individuals were dying from radiation
sickness scythe ended up showing up into
like major tourist areas and major
metropolitan areas and releasing a virus
that in turn infected the rest of the
world and that's how for the most part
most of humanity fell now i say most
because we're familiar with the history
of maestro and we're familiar with the
kingdom of dotopia dystopia so we know
that not everybody on earth died
but a huge percentage something like 90
of humanity was killed between the
viruses and between the nuclear strike
now this is where things get a little
interesting and in fact it's actually
peter david
building on his own story because
originally we weren't told that there
was a virus that was released we were
simply just told it was a nuclear war
that took place between all the various
uh the various nations that were out
there
and it basically led to the collapse of
pretty much all of humanity but as the
incredible hulk leaves right as he's
allowed to leave by modoc and these guys
to get out there and
actually see what's there because the
hulk needs to see for himself so he
knows what's really going on that he
kind of kind of makes this this comment
to himself
if it really was a nuclear war why
didn't the superheroes stop it and then
he answers his own question and says
probably because they didn't right like
you have mass shootings the superheroes
don't really care about that they focus
on the red skull the superheroes could
have stopped chernobyl but they didn't
the superheroes could have stopped the
fall of the twin towers but they didn't
right like there's all these major
calamities that the superheroes could
have stopped but they didn't for one
reason or another and so sure it makes
sense that if world war three was going
to happen by the time it started there
was nothing the superheroes could do and
so once he actually once we actually get
out there into los
angeles which this bunker is located
below but once we actually get out into
the city of la it is
totally completely and totally decimated
and it really gives credence to the idea
that it was a nuclear holocaust that
happened throughout the entirety of the
world as a result of the conflict
between russia and the united states and
that seemingly this virus seems to also
have had an impact we don't really know
what the impact of this virus is we
haven't gotten to it yet but basically
yeah and it's one of these things where
the incredible hulk's kind of like i
mean even if the superheroes wanted to
do anything
there really isn't anything they could
do right like you can't save a world
this destined to destroy itself
in the hulk's mind it was only a matter
of time before something like this
happened it was only a matter of time
before humanity used its vaunted freedom
the thing it loved so much
to wipe itself out but ultimately you
know the incredible hulk just kind of
like yeah i guess it's true like i guess
it really
is true that this is exactly what
happened they really did destroy
themselves and so where he ends up going
to the hollywood sign and modoc meets
with him and asks him why did you come
here he says like is this the only thing
left
is this it is this bunker that we have
down here with advanced idea mechanics
is this
it is this all that's left and the
response of modoc is if you go out there
it'll just be more of the same
like that's really all you're going to
find there really doesn't seem to be
anything else out there now we don't
really know how modok knows this or if
he even knows it at all right we can
kind of
assume that modoc knows this because of
the fact that advanced idea mechanics
use our technology to survey the world
right because we have to assume that
like on some levels satellites are still
functioning and advanced idea mechanics
has their own satellites and has had
them
for a very long time and so even if it
only contains simple satellite imagery
they could literally tap into them and
just sort of canvas the world and that's
when modoc really kind of comes in and
says like come back with us
there's a reason why captain america is
not down here or black widow or any of
those guys because there was no future
to save what we needed were people who
could survive radiation poisoning people
like you like the incredible hulk who
can cope with gamma radiation we had you
in the state of suspended animation so
that when the time came when we went
back to the surface we could wake you up
and we could acclimate you to the world
as it exists right now
and hopefully you wouldn't go on the
kind of rampage that you did but at the
very least we could get things back to a
state of normalcy we could try to
rebuild and ultimately the incredible
hulk's response is
no i don't want to be a part of that
process i'm going to go out there like i
don't need friends right
friends die you know like stop calling
me dr banner my name is not dr banner
anymore and he suddenly just kind of
refers to himself as the hulk and when
muldock asks is that who you are now
like are you just the hulk the response
of the hulk himself is
for now but we'll end up seeing what the
future brings right so this is the first
issue guys
it's exciting the next issue comes out
at the end of september right so it's a
monthly series but if you guys are new
here the comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later oh wait a
minute there's there's one thing we've
been missing from our outro
and we need it we need to bring this
back okay with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah i
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
is